[موسيقى]
إذا لم تكن معجبًا بالأهرامات
فأنت إما أحمق أو
أسوأ من ذلك،
الطقس عن قرب ومن بعيد
لا يهم كم مرة رأيتها
مذهلة بحجمها وتاريخها،
فمجرد وجودها على هذه الأرض هو
مرحبًا يا Marvel، كيف
حالك، كيف قاموا ببناءك على الأرض،
لا كاميرتي ولا مهاراتي الضعيفة
ستفيهم بالعدالة، لكنني التقطت Snap
Snap على أي حال، يا لها من صورة، يا لها من صورة، يا لها من
صورة،
انظر إليها،
الشيء المتعلق بالأهرامات
لا يمكنك التوقف عن التقاط صور لهم
معتقدًا باستمرار أن هذه هي الصورة، لا، هذه هي
الصورة، آه، هذه هي الصورة، وعندما
تعود إلى المنزل، تكون قد حصلت للتو على عدد كبير
من صور
الحجارة مرارًا وتكرارًا، سؤال واحد بسيط
يدور دائمًا حولك  رأيي
كيف بنوها كيف فعلوا
ذلك ومازلت لن تتخلى عن أسرارك
وكنوزك النهائية لا أستطيع أن أصدق أنه في هذا
اليوم وهذا العصر يمكننا إرسال رجل إلى
القمر ولكن لا يمكننا مسحه أو مسحه  الأشعة السينية أو السونا
أو أي شيء عميق في قلبك لمعرفة
عدد الغرف والأنفاق التي لا
تزال قائمة، لقد أعربت عن احترامي
لأعظم كنز في مصر
[موسيقى]
وفي حرارة
شمس الصيف الساحقة أصبح من الواضح تمامًا أن
هذه القطعة الرائعة  من الرأس K حان الوقت الآن
لأخرى، أحتاج إلى
قبعة بها القليل من الوزن،
أليس كذلك
[موسيقى]
يا هذا تمامًا مثل هذا، هل هذا
أفضل من ذلك، كم سعر هذه
القبعة BR
15 15 جيد 15 جيد أنا  لقد حصلت على قبعة جديدة،
حصلت على
كريم لطيف وأنا على استعداد لرؤية
بعض الخراب القديم